The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK.
First, it looks
like a lot of people
is outside today, nice weather.
Midterm number one, we will have
that the week after Wednesday
after you come back.
And that's April 4, of course.
And as the email
Jonathan sent out before,
it will be closed book.
But it will allow one sheet, as
much as you can cram into it.
So one sheet notes.
And I'm asking Jonathan to
put the previous example
of the midterm online so you
can use that as an example
and expect the similar level.
And I will cover the
first five chapters.
So-- actually, essentially by
Monday, I'll finish chapter 5.
And so we do have
homework number six, also
due on that same
day, just to say
you need to do the
homework to get familiar
with the content of chapter 5.
Any questions?
OK.
Don't worry.
The purpose is not to test you.
It's just a chance to--
the second midterm is open book.
It's take home.
So this is the first
chapters, in a sense.
Some of you came to me and
say, can you pass the course?
I can't guarantee
you'll pass the course.
But say, I think
if you really know
the content in the
first five chapters,
you should be able to
answer a lot of questions
on the micro/nano
core qualifying exams.
The micro/nano core is in the
form of giving you a paper
to read, and they come
back, answer questions
from different angles.
So that's my feeling
is you should be able.
OK.
So coming back to
the last lecture,
we discussed what's the energy
carried by electromagnetic wave
that's Poynting vector.
And then we took the
plane wave solution
of electromagnetic
wave in a medium,
and we calculate
the Poynting vector.
And from that, we learned
that the energy, the Poynting
vector, decays exponentially,
as is determined
by the absorption
coefficient, which
is a 4 pi kappa over lambda.
And recall, for
optical waves, lambda
is 10 to the minus fifth, right?
So essentially, kappa could
be a very small number, 10
to the minus 7, and it's
very still very important,
because if you do 4 pi,
and 10 to the minus 7
divided by 10 to the
minus 6, you get 1.
And that means it's still 1--
OK, it depends on the
length, of course.
It's the exponential alpha x.
So this x is--
when delta is inverse--
x equals delta, that equals
inverse of the alpha,
this exponential is really 1.
So that delta is the
penetration depth,
as I said, when the
light intensity decays
to exponential minus 1.
So that's the EM wave
propagation inside the medium.
That's a [INAUDIBLE] we said.
And then we started looking at
the reflection and refraction
of an EM wave at an interface.
And for that, we have to be
careful of the polarization.
Say for electric field, if
it's pointing in any direction,
we can decompose it into
a TM wave and a TE wave.
And the plane of
incidence depends
on-- defined based
on the wave vector
of the incident and the norm.
So if the TM is a
transverse magnetic,
that's an electric field
that is in the plane.
That's why the parallel.
This p means parallel
and simple parallel.
And TE is a transverse
electric wave.
And so the electric
field that is
perpendicular to the plane of
the incidence, perpendicular.
And s-- s is probably German
for the perpendicular,
if anybody knows German.
Then we have-- based on the
boundary condition derived
from Maxwell's equation,
we can eventually
write down what's the
reflection coefficient.
there's no reflectance,
because it's
a ratio of the reflected
electrical field.
It's the field ratio.
Reflection coefficient and
transmission coefficient.
So I'm not going to
repeat this formula.
But essentially, you can
calculate the reflectance
based on reflection coefficient
and the transmission
coefficient.
You can calculate
reflectance and transmittance
for any angle of
incidence as long
as you know the refractive index
of both sides of the medium.
And this is, of course,
assuming perfect interface.
Remember, we have not added--
I made a comment of this
wave vector conservation.
So this is a
specular reflection.
And that's what the
Snell law tells us.
So the angle of incidence
equals angle of Reflection
And I say I like to always--
if you want to show your
knowledge, and very useful,
this is always, I
say for my student,
I say a skill that you should
develop over the graduate years
if you haven't developed at
your undergraduate years,
is when you walk
out, you solve over
90% of the problem
in five minutes.
And so they might say it's a
back-of-the-envelope skill,
because so somebody gave
me a material, I'd say, OK,
that's a refractive index range,
and that's what I know roughly
what's the reflection.
So this is a perpendicular
incidence formula.
And that's-- you don't need to
remember the angular dependent.
But this is the one
that I keep in my mind
when I do my back-of-envelope
given any surface.
And so we used glass and
silicon as an example.
So you can see the typical
reflections of these materials.
And I stopped there.
I want to do more discussion.
One, we see if we look at
the Snell law, the incidence,
the wave vector conservation,
so we've got n1 sine theta 1--
theta i-- that's the
angle of incidence--
equals n2 sine theta t.
This is the transmittance.
So we have-- this is the light
comes in, and typically air,
which is a vacuum--
pretty much a vacuum
depending on the wavelength.
And the refractive index is 1.
And then inside the material,
typically refractive index
is larger than 1.
And so your angle is bending--
the refractive angle
theta t becomes smaller.
So this is Snell's law.
But you could have
a opposite case,
where the light is traveling
inside the medium and goes out.
t.
After it goes to
the first surface,
it may go, say,
inside the medium.
And so in that case, if n1--
so if n1 is larger
than n2, and you
can see my reflective
angle, theta t,
is larger than theta i.
So this is my theta t.
It's larger than theta i.
And then eventually, you
come to the situation
where the theta
t goes 90 degree.
So you ask, what
happens after that.
So if theta t equals 90
degrees, you get a sine theta i.
And we say this is a critical
angle equals to n2 over n1.
And you can see this
ratio is less than 1.
So this angle-- above this
angle, where theta i is larger
than theta i critical and
you go to check the, say,
reflectance and
transmittance formula,
and you'll find that r equals 1.
So the light is
totally reflected.
Reflectance is 100%.
So r equals 1.
And that's the total reflection.
So total-- sometimes the
total internal reflection--
So this is-- internal
means, for example,
if you go from inside
the glass into air,
the light is confined
in the glass.
And so it's interesting.
You can put in the
typical number.
If this is air, it's going
from glass to air, air is 1,
glass is 1.5.
So 1 by 1.5 arcsine.
I think in that case,
I get 42 degrees.
So that's actually
a very large angle.
If you have glass, and--
what it means, if this is 42,
so any light with an incidence
angle larger than 42 degrees
will not escape the glass.
OK.
So this is the principle
of optical fibers.
So optical fiber
has an inner core.
And then say it
has an outer core.
And this outer core has a
smaller refractive index.
So during the glass
deposition, pulling they
change the composition
all of the outer layer
to make the outer layer
smaller refractive index,
so that when your
light comes in,
it will keep bending inside.
So when you use
the optical fiber,
you don't want to
bend it really sharp,
because that angle
of incidence will
be above the critical angle,
the light will leak out.
And in fact, yesterday I was
in Baltimore having lunch with
somebody who was-- he
said he talked to--
you know this optical
fiber was awarded a Nobel
Prize a few years back.
So it's a very simple idea.
And he said that he--
because I was having lunch
with somebody from Corning,
so we're talking glass.
And this guy was saying that
he asked the Corning inventor
about the idea at the time.
It was proposed--
he was proposing
using this for the
communication application,
and how people reacted.
And people were just
saying, that's crazy.
You're thinking about glass.
Because before that,
everybody used communication
in electrical wires.
Going from wire,
electrical wire, to glass,
you can see some of the
even very simple idea
actually gets very
hard to be accepted.
This internal reflection is
really simple physics-wise,
right?
But there are a
lot of neat ideas
and a lot of applications.
And if you are engineer,
the simpler is better.
And I can share a few.
So if you think about
I said glass is 1.5.
If you do silicon,
silicon is 3.5.
1 over 3.5 arcsine gives you 16.
Here I have 16.6 degrees.
So which means
sitcom, all the light
about 16 degree coming to
the surface doesn't go out.
So this is where people
use this idea to do
light trapping in silicon.
We said silicon is an
indirect semiconductor.
It's not good absorption.
And so if somehow if
you think about this,
OK, I have surface here.
I've got a roughness coming in.
The light comes in here.
So that's reflected
over angle into here.
And then the outer
surface is-- if it's
totally internal reflected,
it will come back.
So you have the longer
distance and bounce more times.
And that's how you can
reduce the thickness
and yet still achieve higher
absorption, light trapping.
And this is a still very
active field of research.
This is geometric optics.
We're just talking about
trajectory of light,
didn't consider the phase.
But how to actually achieve
maximum light trapping
with the smallest material
is-- we have, for example,
a DOE project trying to
make thinnest solar cell.
But they still have--
silicon based, but still
achieve high efficiency.
And let me give you another--
there are many, many
examples using this.
I remember the peak cell for
the optics, the photonics,
if you're, say, a few--
probably around 10 years
ago, there was a big bubble,
like housing bubble--
not as large.
But the stock went
through the roof.
A lot of optics communication
companies got very rich.
And one, because
that's the internet,
and after that
it's the internet.
So one of the challenges is how
you switch light directions.
And there was this neat
idea doing MEMS switching,
micro switching.
So this idea was to say,
basically you have a channel,
and you have light comes in.
And it's typically totally
internally reflected,
so it doesn't go through.
And then next time
you push a liquid
that has the same
refractive index as a glass
or very close, in that
case, you an index match.
It doesn't have a total
internal reflection anymore,
so it just goes through.
It's a very simple idea.
And I think that was from HP.
I don't think they were
successful commercializing it,
the study.
And in fact, all the
lasers use this effect.
So not all but the most lasers.
So the solid state
laser, what it has
is a quantum well, very
thin gallium arsenide.
And this is--
quantum well is where
electrons and holes recombine
and give off a photon.
And the thickness of the
world is about 100 angstrom
or thinner.
But the light wavelength
is much larger.
So what it has is another--
there is another
cladding optical layer.
So this is the charge.
And the electromagnetic
wave goes this way.
And the refractive index of the
surrounding layer is smaller.
So the light is forced to bounce
along the layer direction.
So this effect is the widely
used in many, many devices.
Very simple, and it's a
total internal reflection.
OK.
But what's-- there is even
something more interesting.
And that is, you can see
that when theta i is larger
than theta, say, above critical
angle, the reflectance is 1.
But t, the transmission
coefficient is not 1--
0.
And in fact, you can go to check
the transmission coefficient
for we derive is 2
n1 and cosine theta i
and n2 cosine theta
i plus n1 sine--
cosine theta t.
OK.
Cosine theta t, I didn't
say mathematically.
I didn't say it's 1--
it's 0, because we have--
theta i is larger than
critical of angle of incidence.
That means I can still use
Snell's law, sine theta i.
Mathematically, that's a
solution of Maxwell equation.
Didn't say Maxwell
equation didn't exclude it.
So theta i, if you
go to go to do this,
you'll see it's a larger
than 1, sine theta 1.
And-- no, sine theta t,
the angle of transmittance.
It's imaginary.
You go sine-- that's
an imaginary number.
And cosine theta t equals 1
minus sine theta t squared.
And this is larger than 1, so
this is an imaginary number.
Right so let's say
it's i times d.
So I substitute this
one into the-- back
into the transmission
coefficient, ti's now 0.
And I look at the field
on the other side.
So if you look at the
transmitted field, of course,
it's proportional to the
transmission coefficient.
And the incident field, maybe
the anger is not quite right.
So let me write it just
in the proportional.
And then I have my exponential
factor, the phase factor
minus i omega t minus
n2x sine theta t
plus n2z cosine theta t over c0.
So that's my-- this
is not zero this
is the incident cry my electric
field on the other side
is not 0.
And what happens is cosine
theta t is imaginary.
When cosine theta
t is imaginary,
I have an imaginary
number here, I
have another imaginary
number here, it
gives me a real number.
And that real number is
the exponential decay.
So my electric field
on the other side
is exponential decay function.
And this is the evanescent wave.
So when my anger n1 is n2,
and the angle of incidence
a larger than critical
angle, the electrical field
on the other side, exponential
decay from the surface.
And the real part,
the x component,
if you look at n2 sine theta
t equals n1 sine theta i,
so that's actually real.
So this wave, what
you have is a wave
propagating in the x-direction
on the surface and decays
exponentially on the other side.
And this is the evanescent wave.
OK.
And but you say, how
is that possible?
You have a field, the
transmission is not--
is 0.
So what it happens is you go to
calculate, although the t is,
itself is not 0, but tau,
the transmitted energy, is 0.
The average Poynting
vector is 0.
So the field comes
in, goes out back.
So average speaking, there's no
net energy going from one side
to the other.
That's what the evanescent wave.
And recall in the case
of discussing electrons,
that's our situation, right?
We, say, OK your energy of
the electron comes in, goes--
so if the energy is less
than the barrier height,
your wave function on
this side is not 0.
But you calculated
the material flux,
the particle flux is
0 on the other side.
That's an evanescent
field for material wave.
So all waves have
this characteristic.
And how fast the decay?
You go to check,
here is essentially,
if you say omega-- or
C0 and the theta divide,
it's of the order of wavelength.
So that decay is of the
order of wavelength.
And then we said that,
OK, for material wave,
the wavelength maybe
is a few angstroms.
Last time, we said people use
that to do the IBM interview
example I told you, [INAUDIBLE]
got a scanning tunneling
microscope.
And so you use the
evanescent wave for material
with electrons.
Here, you get the evanescent
wave on the other side.
And there are a lot of,
say, different applications.
And I'll discuss more later on.
OK.
So this is the Snell's
law and evanescent wave.
And let me also make
one more comment,
because here, all our
derivation is assuming n1,
n2, they are real.
And if n2 is
complex, and go-- you
go to check your equation,
derivation process, no problem.
Everything still is applicable.
It's a mathematical solution
of the Maxwell equation.
So what it means is when you
look at your Snell's law,
n1 sine theta 1, the i-- let
me assume n1 is real first.
And you go-- you
get n2 is complex,
so sine theta t is complex now.
So sine theta t is complex.
It's a plus bi.
And cosine theta t, you
do operation, c plus di.
So both are complex.
And then so the same formula,
you do your complex number
operation.
But when both are complex, you
go to look at your wave here.
Sine theta t is complex.
Cosine theta t-- OK, in
fact, here it will be real.
But what you will find out
is that this wave, inside,
when it propagates
into a medium,
the constant
amplitude is actually,
in the z-direction, the
constant amplitude surface.
The amplitude,
that's when z, each z
equals constant that field
is a constant amplitude.
But constant phase is going
in the other direction.
So the constant phase
and constant amplitude
actually do not coincide.
And this is an
inhomogeneous wave.
But say all the formula
we gave still applicable.
So there's no problem as long
as you do your complex number
operation consistently.
And I remember that in old
days, I only know Fortran,
so you have to be very
careful to declare
your complex numbers.
Otherwise, you
run into problems.
One more.
What if our n1 is also complex?
n1 is also complex.
And this is a point that
probably most people
don't know.
Everything is still applicable.
So most people know that.
But if you do your
operation, you'll
find that R plus tau
do not equal to 1.
And at the surface,
there's an absorption.
So I-- actually, I
remember what I found this
out when I was a graduate
student doing all the math.
And I said, what's
happening there?
I went-- I went to ask
my professor and said,
that's strange.
So I went to check
a lot of books.
I thought that I
could write a paper.
It turns out I was
only 100 years late.
It was Max Born,
in fact, that they
discussed all those issues.
Max Born is--
Born got the--
I forgot whether he got
a Nobel prize or not.
But it's all in there,
discussed before.
OK.
So this is all the discussion
that I didn't finish.
And so we now know at least
how to calculate the reflection
of electron at the interface.
We gave a normal incidence.
I said that you should
be able to do any angle.
We did the electromagnetic
wave at the interface.
And the next one
is acoustic wave.
So all these waves are
similar, but the equations
are different.
One is the
Schroedinger equation.
Here is the Maxwell equation.
So let me briefly talk
about acoustic wave.
This is my last, because
I go from simpler
to more complicated.
And material wave, in fact,
the Schroedinger equation
there is a scalar.
Maxwell equation is a
transverse wave, two components.
And you learned the
phonon's acoustic wave,
has three components--
longitudinal
with two transverse waves.
So your equation will
be a lot more complex.
And in the continuum
limit, in continuum limit,
you can write a set of
differential equation
for acoustic wave
propagation in a medium.
And the way to derive that
equation is starting from F
equals ma.
There are not many equations.
And so the F equals ma.
And then we need to say,
inside the material,
how I can convert this into
the atomic displacement?
Because acoustic wave,
essentially the atoms--
the material displacement
from equilibrium position.
So if you say, OK, displacement
is the r minus r0--
that's the
equilibrium position--
then a is just the derivative,
second-order derivative.
So now you can try to see how
you can relate both sides so
that you get one equation--
one question for displacement or
velocity of the material wave.
And the way you do it
is think about the force
is related to stress
in the material.
And stress is related to strain.
Strain is related
to displacement.
So if you write all
those relations,
you immediately get a wave
equation for the displacement.
And that's the
acoustic equation.
OK, just a few more on that.
And what you have here is the
strain, typical way of writing
strain--
I'm not going to write
all the equations.
So strain is a
tensor and is defined
as dui dxj plus duj dxi.
That's the strain.
And stress tensor-- so we have--
what's the Hooke's
law in the material,
in the complicated form,
the most general form,
is really a tensor.
So the force-- the stress
is related to the strain.
And it's related
to the strain, s.
So these two hats means
second-order tensor.
And that coefficient is the
stiffness-- material stiffness,
elastic stiffness, constant.
And this one is
something times tensor.
It's actually-- to get
a second-order tensor
from a second-order
tensor multiplication,
this should be a
fourth order tensor.
So this is really
fourth-order tensor.
And each order is a
three-component vector
with three components.
Second-order tensor
has nine components.
Fourth order tensor
is 81 components.
So anybody doing
solid mechanics,
you must be very good at math.
That's a lot of
tensor operation.
And in the case of--
in, fact that you
can do symmetry.
You can simplify 81 to 36.
And if you get a isotopic
material, you get only two so.
That's what the different
assumptions mean.
But essentially, so
you have displacement,
you have your stress,
and your force.
Generally, if you
have a surface,
you have a norm, you have
stress tensor here, sigma.
You have n is norm.
Then they say, is
the stress tensor
the normal times
a stress tensor.
That gives you the force
acting on that surface.
So essentially, here
those relations can me--
if I substitute everything
back into the F equals ma,
I should get acoustic wave
equation in the material.
But except here, if you have
to look at this, I should--
I know this one,
I get the time--
second-order time derivative.
On the left-hand side, I should
get the space second-order
derivative to get the
wave equation, right?
So the way I just
wrote the F equation
sigma will give a sigma
equals proportional to s.
That's only first
order in space.
That's not second
order in space yet.
And the reason is, you have
to do your finite element
analysis.
So you take a
differentiable volume.
You have force difference.
That's the left force.
That difference will give
you the space second-order
derivative.
And so you get the
second-order derivative
on the left-hand side,
second-order time derivatives
in the right-hand side.
You get the wave equation
that's acoustic wave equation.
You can see if I write it down,
it will be very, very long.
So this is-- in
general, you can have
the equation for acoustic wave.
And you can also calculate
there is also acoustic
Poynting vector.
That's the energy.
The time average, the
acoustic Poynting vector--
this is not the strain--
Poynting vector is 1/2
real part of velocity,
which is the
first-order derivative,
and times this stress tensor.
So this is like the
force times the velocity
gives you the work.
That's the acoustic
energy flux there.
OK.
And now, what happens
for acoustic wave
coming towards the interface?
And when we have
electromagnetic wave,
we have, of course,
reflection and refraction.
And that's the same we have.
But it depends on
whether the incoming wave
is a longitudinal wave,
is a transverse wave.
And if it's a transverse
wave, which direction
I project the
plane of incidence.
And so if the displacement
is in the plane of incidence,
that's an SV wave.
And here, longitudinal
wave, this is L wave.
And in most general case, what
happens is you do your-- again,
at the interface you
have boundary condition,
and you can derive--
and it turns out,
in general case SV
wave or a longitudinal
wave can excite three wave.
You can have also
longitudinal wave.
You can have SV wave and SH--
SH is the other
polarization perpendicular
to the plane of incidence.
So that's the complication
for acoustic waves--
you have mode conversion from
one mode, one polarization
to other polarization.
And because of this, you can
also have transmitted also
have three polarizations.
And if it's isotropic medium,
you only have two branches.
So this will be
degenerate, and you
can have L waves and
the transverse wave.
So this is the general case.
And the formula, in fact--
there was a really
good book when--
that's a book by Auld.
I would suggest for anybody
interested in those, because it
actually treats Maxwell equation
and acoustic wave equations
side by side.
And that gives a
very good learning.
And when I read acoustic
wave, so that's the--
I know Maxwell question, that's
how I learned acoustic wave.
OK.
And now if you go to do--
I'm not going to give you
any angular relation the.
Reflectance of acoustic wave.
At the lower incidence, it's
very similar to the reflectance
of optical wave at
lower incidence,
and same as the electron
waves at lower incidence.
So reflectance is z1 minus
z2 and z1 plus z2 squared.
Well, this is-- z is density
times velocity square root.
And this is acoustic impedance.
So it's density times
velocity, speed of sound.
You can roughly think that.
And again, it's the difference
in acoustic impedance
that gives the reflection
of acoustic waves.
And you can write
the Snell's law.
And for example, you're--
the problem is for
Snell's law, this
is the vi, velocity
of the incident wave.
But even on the same side,
you can have reflection
into other angle due
to mode conversion.
The lateral momentum,
the kx, has to conserve.
That's the Snell's law.
And so what you have is
even for the same side--
let's say reflected also
for longitudinal, let's say.
Then you have to see
the longitudinal wave,
there's the angle
there, angular relation,
that essentially tells you the
lateral momentum conservation.
And then for the other
side, you have similar.
If it's transmitted,
wave t transmitted,
on the, let's say, reflective
side, transmitted side.
So those are the
corresponding Snell's laws
for acoustic waves.
So again, you can have the--
if you look at those
relations, you can still
have total internal reflection.
Acoustic wave can also be
totally internally reflected.
So if you go from
medium, like, say--
I think it's germanium,
for example, to silicon.
If you launch,
say, lattice wave,
and you look at
the relation, there
is a total critical angle.
And above the critical
angle, it will reflect
total internal reflection.
And then on the other side, you
have correspondingly evanescent
wave.
It doesn't carry energy
to the other side.
But at the time it got there
is vibration exponential decay
from the surface.
So all those waves
have similar phenomena.
And so the equations you start
with could be very different.
But general wave behavior
share a lot of similarities.
OK.
So that's waves at
a single interface.
And what we're
moving on there is,
what about multiple interfaces?
And single interface is only
reflection, refraction--
I do want-- before
I reach this, I
do want to make another comment.
We said that, OK, because
this is Snell's law, if you
put any of the negative,
you draw your light, how
the refraction should happen,
then if n is negative,
it goes this way.
Your theta goes the other way.
So that's why at
the beginning, there
are a lot of news
articles of light bends
the wrong way, all this
stuff, with electromagnetic
metamaterials.
OK.
So what we are approaching next
is multi layers, thin films.
In thin films.
So when I-- I said that
before we have one interface.
Now let's go to two interfaces.
And so to go from two
interfaces to any interface
is actually quite
straightforward.
And so the physics,
what happens is
I have the wave comes
in the first interface.
And let's say n1, n2, n3.
My formula is written
in terms of small n,
but you can write it capital
N. Everything is identical.
And so what happens is
that the first interface,
you have refraction,
you have reflection.
You can use your Fresnel formula
to calculate the reflection
and refraction, transmit it.
And when it comes to the
second, you propagate.
We know how to write the wave
propagation, the phase factor
here.
We have the phase factor.
That's my phase factor.
So when the z charges, I
know how to write it up
for different media.
And then at the second
interface, you have reflection,
you have transmission.
And once it's
transmitting into n3,
I don't have
anything coming back,
so I can say that
part is going forward.
This one coming
back is troublesome,
because it comes back
into the interface again.
And then I get, again,
transmission from 2 to 1.
And reflection,
every time I can use
my Fresnel formula plus the
propagating phase factor
to trace it.
So transmission, reflection.
And that's one way to do it.
You add up the field, you
use the Fresnel formula.
But it's pretty tedious.
I can say-- you can say it's an
infinite series, because there
are infinite number of
reflection and transmission
in theory.
So that's-- you trace the field.
And if you don't consider the
phase, of the light in EM wave,
then that's-- people do--
this is pretty much like Monte
Carlo.
People do ray tracing.
They trace the trajectory
of light bundles.
And there are
commercial code to do
that in complicated geometry.
But when you have those
phase also changing,
it becomes a lot more
complicated to actually trace
and carry your
phase of the field,
and not very
computationally efficient.
So at least for thin films,
flat structures, there
different way--
other ways to do it.
And the next way is
here, at each interface,
I can use the Fresnel formula.
But see, the last one is--
I don't care about the--
I add this all together,
because the phase vector
is same for each one.
So OK, I say, this
is my incidence,
this is a total
resulting reflection.
And this is my total
forward propagating
and my reflected
propagating inside the film.
And this is my
total transmittance.
And in that case, I do not know
the relation between this point
at this point, because
this point is summing up
many of those forward.
Same, this is a summing
up many backward.
So I have to use my
boundary condition
to refine the relations among
the incident, reflected.
Here is forward,
backward, transmitted.
So this is another way to do
it using boundary condition.
And this is a resulting wave.
Let's say positive,
this is a backward
propagating reflective incident.
And of course, there are
different polarization.
If I consider TM
wave, then that's
what I have to do as we
do a single in plane.
And here is transmitted.
So that's a way that I'm going
to follow through the math.
And even this way--
this way is pretty
intuitive mathematically.
But even this way is
not very convenient
if you have many layers.
And if you have many layers, the
best is using a matrix format.
And the matrix format is not--
I consider total electric field.
This is incident
reflective, right?
But I don't distinguish
the incident reflective.
The total local electric field
and the total magnetic field--
so here I have--
and the point I want to
use is the continuity.
If you recall, the boundary
condition for EM wave
is at the interface, I have
the tangential component
of electric field,
the magnetic field,
as long as there's no
sheet current there,
is equal on both sides.
So what I'm going
to do is I use--
I know the phase factor from
this point to this point
and from this point
to this point.
So I know, actually, the
relation-- the phase--
the relation between the
electric and magnetic field
between these two points.
And these two points
will be reflected as--
let's say I have Ex 0 Hy 0--
that's at this point--
relate to this point
through a matrix.
And that matrix, you can
get from the solution
of Maxwell equation.
And then to this point is Ex--
let's say here I have
d is the thickness--
and Hy d.
So this matrix will make
my life much easier,
because if I know the-- so
you relate the electric field
total--
it's not forward backward.
It's added up all
forward and backward,
total electric field--
total magnetic
field at this point
through the-- total
electric field,
total magnetic field
through a matrix element.
And I know my continuity is
propagating to the other side.
This electric field
and magnetic field
is the same on both sides.
So this point is the
same as this point.
So I can connect the many,
many layers together just
by matrix
multiplication, continue
this to build up any layer.
So this one is most
convenient to use.
And that's transfer matrix.
And in fact, the transfer
matrix is used widely
for many different problems.
There are people dealing
with the multi-layer heat
conduction.
And in that case,
your continuity
is temperature and heat flux at
the interface and continuous.
So using that, if you can
relate the temperature and heat
flux at this point to this
point and across the interface
continues, so you just
write a similar matrix,
and you do your matrix
multiplication for many layers.
So it's a very useful
mathematical approach
for many different problems.
But what I'm going to do is
spend a little time here.
And let's use this to
get the basic idea how
I'm going to do multi layers.
And what we need to
write down is essentially
like two-interface condition.
Before last lecture,
we wrote one interface,
we had two equations.
And now I have two
interfaces, and I
need to write a propagating--
the phase I need to carry.
Because from this
point to this point,
there's a distance traveled.
And if I look at this plane
wave when go z is moving.
Omega doesn't-- is the
same, and the x component,
that's what is the
Snell's law take care.
So this one, I don't--
I don't need to worry.
All Snell's law is always valid.
And omega t, I
don't need to worry.
What I need to worry is
carrying this phase term,
this z term, because I go from--
this is my z direction.
When I go from this point
to this point, I have--
this is the original 0 to d.
That's my z.
OK.
So what I have, you can
write your Ei, the incident,
and the exponential minus
i, the phase factor,
I write the z direction n2--
no, see, n1-- n1 cosine
theta i and lambda z.
So this is my incident.
And similarly,
reflected-- so you
have to be comfortable
in carrying
this positive n1 cosine theta i.
Because of the
Snell's law, so theta,
the angle is the same, z.
So this is the incident
reflective in medium 1.
And same, you can write the
transmitted, before plug
in the E plus.
Like I said, I do not--
this is not just--
the origin is not just from Ei.
It's from the model reflection.
So I don't know the relation.
So I want to say this is E,
let's say, plus exponential.
Phase factor inside
is i n2 cosine theta--
let's say here I'm using 2--
and lambda z.
And E minus exponential, that
is the opposite direction,
n2 cosine theta 2 lambda z.
You can also write the
transmission there.
Now I apply the continuity,
the same boundary condition
as I did before, for
the first interface
and for the second interface.
The tangential component of
the electric and magnetic field
are continuous.
So for the first interface,
when I take my original of z
equals 0, cleverly
choosing your coordinate,
so that is the
tangential component,
so Ei times cosine theta i
plus Er cosine theta r equals
E plus cosine theta 2 plus
E minus cosine theta 2.
So that's the tangential
component on then two
sides, this side and this side.
Remember, I always
add up the total.
I didn't say it's the incident.
It's the total electric field.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the theta
r from the [INAUDIBLE]??
GANG CHEN: Yeah, I'm sorry.
So this one is the same.
Theta i and theta r
is the same, theta i.
So the Snell's law.
And then the
magnetic field is n--
remember, it's n1 mu
C0 and Ei minus Er.
That's the relation with
the Hy we derived last time.
The relation-- if I
know electric field,
I know the magnetic field.
It's n mu C times
the electric field.
For opposite propagating,
because of the direction
change.
My right-handed rule, I have
a negative sign in the front.
And the same is n2 mu C0
E plus and minus E minus.
So this is the
amplitude, E plus E
minus, of the forward
propagating and backward
propagating waves.
And of course, I need
two other equations,
because I have E plus, E
minus unknown, Er unknown,
and also transmitted unknown.
I need four more-- two more
equations to close this.
That's at the other interface.
I have two interfaces.
Each interface gives
me two equations.
So the other
interface, now you have
to carry your phase
factor, because when
the wave propagating from 0
to d, so you have to write z
equals d now.
Again, your electric field
is the E plus here projecting
into the x direction.
This is my x direction.
It's cosine theta.
So it's cosine theta
2 exponential i phi--
minus i phi 2.
Phi 2 is my phase factor.
That's to say you can look
at that as n2 cosine theta 2.
So let me write it down.
So phi 2 equals n2 cosine
theta 2 over lambda times d.
So E minus i phi 2 plus E minus
and cosine theta 2 E i phi 2--
this is a backward, going back.
So the z wave vector
is going backwards,
so that's my plus
wave, plus sign.
And then say my Et transmitted.
So Et cosine theta t
exponential minus i phi 3.
And this phi 3 is you do
n3 cosine theta 3 lambda
all times d.
It doesn't matter.
In fact, you can restart your
coordinates, this phase factor
at the end, because when you
calculate the transmitted,
this cancels or
drops out this phase
factor when you do the ratio.
And so I have the
magnetic field is n2 mu
C0 E plus minus E minus.
And this is n3 mu C0 and Et
exponential minus i phi 3.
Now I have four equations,
I can solve for the--
what I want is really the
reflecting to incident--
that's reflectance--
reflection coefficient,
transmitted to incident--
that's the transmission
coefficient.
So I have enough equations
to solve that problem.
And what you find is your r
equals Er over Ei equals r12--
that's the Fresnel coefficient
between 1 and 2 interface--
plus r23-- that's
Fresnel coefficient--
exponential 2 i phi
2 and divided by 1
plus r12 r23
exponential 2 i phi 2.
So this is the
reflection coefficient.
And similarly, you can do
your transmission coefficient.
The Et Ei equals t12
t23 exponential i phi 2,
and 1 plus r12 r23
exponential 2 i phi 2.
So some comments here.
So you can see the transmission,
you have E i phi 2.
That's the first pass.
So it doesn't have double there.
And the denominator, reflecting
that it's always double,
so you have 2 i phi 2,
double the back and forth.
If you look at this,
the next transmission
is reflecting, come
back, and go out.
Reflection is the first one.
And then the next one is
have to go forward, reflect,
go back, go out.
So that's where this
factor of 2 comes from.
And second, you will say
that if you square this,
you'll get a sine
cosine, so you get
an interference, periodical
variations of reflectance
and transmittance as a
function of this phase factor.
So that's the
interference effect.
OK.
And I do want to
get the math done.
So let me first
give you the math
and then do the discussion
in the next lecture.
So I have gone through the
result and the wave method
and really, say, split
the electric field
into forward and backward.
But I said that if I do this,
it's still not very convenient.
And the best thing
is to do this--
transfer matrix.
And using the fact that the
both electric and magnetic field
are continuous at the interface,
so what I need is to write.
So here, I'm going to ask you
to read more detail in the book.
And if I do, I want to
get the transfer matrix.
But eventually, I
have to also come back
to what I care is the ratio.
So I care about reflecting
the electric field divided
by incident.
So I have--
I said what I do in
math is the total.
Total electric
field is continuous,
total magnetic is continuous.
But at the end, I really want
to still have to separate them
for incident and reflection.
So I need a matrix
to relate that.
And so if you do
your electric field--
so this is at 0.
This is my z, and this is my x.
And let's say this
is a 1, this is a 2.
And so 1, x component
0, is Eix plus the Erx.
And H1y at 0, so I'm
considering a TM wave.
So H1y is n1 mu C0
and Ei minus Ex.
You can see now I have a
relation between the incident
reflected electric
field to total incident
electric field, total
incident magnetic field.
I can inverse this.
And so I write into matrix.
So this one, essentially
what-- because I
want to write everything to
matrix, H0, H1, 1, and here
is 0.
And this is 1, 1, 1 over p1,
minus 1 over p1, and Eix, Erx.
So I have a--
this p1 is the
surface impedance.
So it's Ex Hy.
And for the TM wave, we have
this cosine theta and n mu C0.
So this is for TM wave.
And TE wave, you can write
a different expression.
So what I wrote down here is
the total electrical field,
total magnetic field
related to incident
reflected electric
field through matrix.
So that's either the first
side, because eventually I
want to find the Ei/Er relation,
not just the H/E relation.
But see, what I'm using is
E, and the H is continuous.
So E and H--
so E1x 0, E1y 0 should
equal E2x 0, H2y 0.
So that's the continuity
of tangential component.
So the second is my--
if you do your-- if you go back
to what we just written down
on the electric field and
relate to magnetic field,
you'll find out is H2--
no.
E2x 0 and the H2y 0, so I
want to relate this point
to this point.
That's in the same media.
That's just the phase factor.
So if I do that relation,
that gave me matrix.
So this point is related
to the other point.
What I want is E2x
at d, H2y at d.
So this is this point here,
here, these two points.
And in between is
this matrix I want.
And that's cosine phi 2 minus
i p2 sine phi 2 and minus i
p2 sine phi 2 and cosine phi 2.
So this is my M,
transfer matrix.
That's what I was
saying here, OK?
And the beauty of this
is I relate this point
to this point.
Now, if I add another layer,
layer 3, between here and here
is continuous.
So this point is
also this point.
Now, to find this point, I
tie my M's, the other M here.
If this is M1, this is M2.
I times another M, I will
relate to this point.
So with the transfer
matrix, this is my M.
And see, if I have N layers,
it's just M1 times M2 times MN.
So I can do any layers easily.
OK.
And finally is my
transmitted, the last one.
When it goes out, it does not
have anything coming back.
So I still need
to relate to that.
So my final relation is--
let's say if this is
transmitted, Ex d Hy d.
And it equals 1, 1 over p3
Etx, because in this case,
this is my 1, 2, 3, and
the transmitted field
only has one forward
propagating, not backward.
So I have a simple--
with this, if you can see,
I can use all this relation.
The first one-- because this one
is continuous equal this one,
so I have, you can
see, this matrix--
1, 1-- let me don't do this.
I will use this one as my--
this is my-- here is my A.
Let's say this is
A. This is a matrix.
So if I use my continuity as
A times Eix Hrx, that's here.
That equals here.
This equals this.
That's equal to this.
So equals M times
this one-- that's
the other interface
that equals this.
So 1, 1 p3, and Etx.
So with this, I can
relate the transmitted
to incident,
reflected to incident.
So this is the--
no matter how many
layers, I just
add in the multiplication
of this matrix.
And when you do--
if do this kind of
calculation, this
is where people
design any coating.
The design coating they'll do
for-- as long as a thin film
coating, you do a
transfer matrix,
and it has various kind
of interference effects
and come into desire--
the desirable value.
And when you do those
kind of operations,
the key is you
have to be careful,
because sometimes this blew up.
And the-- depends on whether,
for example, if your phi itself
is complex, that's actually
exponential function.
This could create trouble.
I think for this
one, what I want to--
I just want to stop here.
Let me not showing the--
I thought I was going to
have some time to browse.
But see, what I want to
say is, if I have not
lost you the first
five chapters,
you can now open any journal.
You can make, say, probably
half of the paper connection
to what you learned.
And I challenge you to look at--
when I say any
journal, like I said,
don't consider the Bioscience.
I haven't talked about that.
You are probably-- I was looking
at the Nano Letters, Energy
and Environmental
Science, Nature Photonics,
Nature Materials.
This morning, I think
I just don't have time
to go through all this with you.
But you should be able
to see there something
that you can relate to, OK?
Any questions?
Well, today is beautiful.
So I'll finish earlier.